looks like we're ready to get started so
I'm John Healy this is all joint work
with Leland McKenna's who some of you
may have seen yesterday and Colin we're
we're mathematicians and researchers at
the Tut Institute for mathematics
computing in Ottawa Canada we're a small
Research Institute focused on sort of
foundational and fundamental data
science algorithms amongst other things
this talk used to be called map all the
things based on an algorithm we wrote
called you map
I've rebranded it embed all the things
in hopes of not confusing the
cartographers in the crowd I apologize
in advance for tricking you all into
coming if you are in fact here very
sorry so what do I mean by all the
things I'm gonna start off we're gonna
talk about fixed with numeric data this
is the traditional data that data
scientists have been dealing with for
years and years now we'll get us ramped
up on that and I'm going to transition
into variable length categorical data
which is typically slightly harder to do
for embedding we're gonna spend some
time talking about that and finally I'm
going to transition into embedding words
and documents all right
because reproducibility matters you can
find both the slides and all of the
notebooks that I used to do most of
these embeddings on this github page
feel free to download them and grab them
and run them my hope is that by the end
of this talk you'll be able to clone
that repo load those notebooks and pivot
them and use them to embed your data and
do real-world things using sort of the
topology and the embedding techniques on
your problems all right last note I've
got a couple of little snippets of code
that are pasted throughout the talk
they're really pictures of code again
the notebooks exists and if he's
reasonably well documented you probably
don't need to be scribbling down lines
of code as you go through either all
right start off what is an embedding if
I'm gonna ask you to embed all the
things I really need to tell you what an
embedding is so this this is an
embedding or a galaxy exploding I'm
never sure which either way an embedding
is a numerical representation of your
data with meaningful distances between
your points so this one is you want a
nice low dimensional representation and
the reason you want to do this typically
is
to explore or look at your data this is
a two-dimensional representation where
each of those dots is an individual
point I've used the lovely data shader
to fold those points on top of each
other so that the very bright or intense
regions of the space are the ones that
have many many points in a very closed
region so you could think of that as
those are clusters or natural groupings
of your data regions with lots and lots
of points in them okay what did I just
say I said an embedding is a numeric
representation of your data along with
the distance you need both in order to
have an embedding if you're gonna do in
supervised learning on anything you have
either explicitly or implicitly chosen a
distance function for your data I'm
going to argue that that choice should
always be explicit so why do you care
why would you actually want to go about
doing any of this stuff and embedding
any of your data in the first place I
hinted at the last slide unsupervised
learning is the it's the right answer so
another phrase you could use to describe
unsupervised learning is data science
with no labels if you have labels or
things you would like to predict you're
doing supervised learning if you don't
have any of that you have to use
unsupervised learning typical tasks and
unsupervised learning or grouping your
data looking for outliers or anomalies
in your data or exploring your data and
visualizing it and looking to see what's
what's going on and there are complex
relationships inside your data so again
we said we want a numerical
representation of our data why because
math so we want to be able to do math on
our data math really likes numbers and I
said you need a distance measure because
I have no labels so math and no labels
I'm going to be doing supervised
learning I'm gonna do embedding now data
we're doing data science here everyone
here's a data scientist I can't do data
science without data doing data science
without data is like making beer without
water or swimming without water whatever
floats your boat let's introduce some
data you should always select data you
really care about you really like you're
really interested in in analyzing so I
chose
beer I brew beer with a friend I find
beer both interesting and delicious so
we're gonna spend some time analyzing it
this is a cattle beer review data set
that you can go and download from this
URL right now and do your own analysis
alright we download it we load it up
into a panda's data frame we do a head
we transpose that we look at the number
of rows this gives you the first couple
of rows of our data and you can see
we've got lots of interesting fields
ways to slice and dice and explore the
data to answer lots of really
interesting questions we might want to
ask about beer so I'm gonna use this
data to show you lots of different ways
to slice dice and embed it to answer a
variety of different questions alright I
think I'd like to think of each of these
ways of slicing dicing and embedding
your data as different lenses through
which you can look at your data every
one of those lenses or every one of
those embeddings is going to tell you
something different about your data and
every one of them is gonna be wrong but
some of them are gonna be useful all
right let's start with a traditional
kind of lens over top of our data fixed
with numerical data this kind of data
that Dinah's scientists made a
scientists have been doing since the ad
dawn of time or at least the dawn of
statistics the first thing we need to do
is select what we're going to embed the
thing we care about very natural choices
for that would be beer you can embed
beer into a vector space that would be
fun we could talk about beer styles
instead you can buy beer styles into a
vector space we could look at reviewers
so we have reviewers who reviewed at
individual beers you could embed them
into a vector space you were more
interested in who was reviewing beers in
your data set or breweries we have the
Brewers that made the beer we can talk
about exploring relationships amongst
breweries that choice depends on the
question you're trying to answer and the
story you're trying to tell all right
for now we're gonna choose to embed beer
styles the next question is with respect
to what features so in other words what
makes two beer styles similar there are
some obvious choices we have
Numerical features we all like numerical
features because we've been doing this
and sort of undergrad data science like
yep I know stuff I can do with numbers
fantastic I am going to select review
aroma appearance palette and taste and
say ah I think that two beer styles are
gonna be similar if they get sort of
similar rankings in these sort of
categories I'm gonna leave out the
overall beer style for now we'll get
back to that later you have a problem
though each of those variables is a
distribution and not a number
so for American IPAs for example if you
look at the taste review it's a
distribution of a hundred and seventeen
thousand different reviews and that's
that distribution that's hard to deal
with we need a number to represent the
taste for the beer style enter pandas
group by so since we need one row per
thing we're interested in in this case
beer style
we're gonna group by beer style that is
going to collapse down and omit one row
per beer style now we need to tell it
how to summarize those hundred and
fourteen thousand numbers that are
associated with taste for that beer
style and so we pass into this group by
object the columns we care about are the
features we care about and how we like
to group or aggregate them in this case
I chose mean it's straightforward it's
simple you could have used median you
could have used truncated mean you could
have used percentiles there's lots of
other things you could use this makes
things clean and simple you'll notice
there a number of other columns we've
included as well at the top there's some
categorical columns like beer name and
beer brewery name means don't make a lot
of sense on these categorical variables
or strings or names so instead we're
just going to take the most frequently
occurring one there now those are about
one I'm going to call background
features we're gonna use them for like
labeling things and enhancing and our
data out after on but we're not gonna
make use of them as part of the actual
embedding all right so I have a four
tuple of features that I care about I've
done my group by I've collapsed down to
one hundred and four rows from my one
point five million reviews there aren't
all that many beer styles and the data
it turns out
and we're gonna use a subset of this
data so the beer reviews are of Pierre
Styles at the top to be the columns that
are going to be our numerical
representation of our data all right now
we've chosen the representation the
other thing I said you needed before you
have an embedding as a distance this is
where it gets hard there's an awful lot
of potential distance measures to choose
from what you choose is ultimately going
to determine your results it's going to
determine which points are similar to
each other so this is going to come down
to you either knowing something about
your feature space or having an
evaluative task that you can try these
things on and see how well it does in
the absence of any extra knowledge I'm
gonna recommend a good rule of thumb as
Euclidean which is L to distance
Manhattan which is l1 distance or cosine
distance which is sort of an angular
distance these are the non-controversial
go-to distance measures you won't have a
hard time arguing with but more
importantly their distance measures that
are easy for you to understand and if
you have to decide fundamentally sort of
as an axiom that this is a meaningful
distance measure on my feature space you
need to understand how that distance
measure is going to behave on your
feature space now the first step there
is looking at your data so look at your
data check your columns see that they're
on the same scales so the distance
across those scales is meaningful in
this case they are notice we didn't
include a DV or alcohol by volume on
this representation even though it's a
number and you know we could Jim bad
things with numbers but if you had
looked at that I didn't include it
because one I don't know that the
difference what the relationship is
between 3 & 4 on a rating scale versus
3% and 4% on an alcohol by volume scale
those are totally different and totally
arbitrarily comparable scales so it's
not a natural one to include in this
case additionally if I'd included ABV
you can see that it's on a wildly
different scale you'd also have this
problem if appearance was rated out of a
hundred
instead of rated out of five those large
scale variables would swamp my distance
measure and that would be the only thing
I would be detecting so you need your
variables to be on similar scales an off
common way to deal with this is s Kaler
and you can normalize or standardize
your data to be looking at standard
deviations instead of looking at the
absolute scores but it turns out we
don't need to do that in this case
everything is on a very nice very
similar scale I look at this I decide l1
distance or Manhattan distance makes a
lot of sense here which is going to be
the sum of the difference between these
four coordinates I had now have a
distance measure and now I have an
embedding beer styles our vector of
their mean scores along with Manhattan
distance this is an embedding I can be
done right now if what I want to do is
clustering or LIRR detection you can go
ahead and do that I would have a
personal preference for HDB scan that's
because we wrote the fast HTTP scan
algorithm the secular cat rib we quite
like it it's a good first clustering
algorithm to run in your data it'll work
on that four dimensional data but it
might not work on really high
dimensional data and another thing you
might want to do instead of clustering
is look at your data so how would you go
about looking at very high dimensional
data or potentially four-dimensional
data even well answer dimension
reduction lots of reason you might want
to do dimension reduction maybe somebody
at a PI data talk told you to look at
your data that's an excellent reason to
do it
doing dimension reduction works there
you might want to visualize it to look
for complex relationships in your data
maybe your data is really high
dimensional and your clustering
algorithm doesn't scale to really high
dimensional data maybe your clustering
algorithm doesn't support the distance
measure you decided was true and you
really wanted to use we're gonna use
dimension reduction algorithm call it
you map to find a low dimensional
Euclidean space that approximates the
disses function you really cared about
all right why you map I hear you ask now
there are a few good dimension reduction
algorithms out there there's popular
ones are PCA and t-sne both solid
algorithms they have their place the
pithy answers to why we develop why
we're using a map is that we
new map and though so we like it the
longer answer is the reason we developed
it was we needed a fast scalable
nonlinear dimension reduction technique
that had strong mathematical
underpinnings alright for those who
attended Leland mcginnises talk
yesterday you already completely
understand you map and the next two
minutes are going to be slightly boring
for you for the rest I'm gonna give you
the thousand foot overview of you map so
you have sort of a vague idea of what
it's going to do and then we're gonna go
and make use of it so that is heart you
map is a manifold learning technique
that is they're going to draw an edge
for every point to its set of nearest
neighbors we're gonna look at that graph
structure we're gonna try to unroll that
graph structure into a low dimensional
space and lay it down there there are a
few more details to keep in mind but
that's really the important part of what
you map is doing it's it's preserving
this look topological structure in your
data alright the key though is that it's
a locality preserving technique if your
data isn't naturally 2-dimensional any
dimension reduction algorithm is going
to be forced to make sacrifices when
embedding in two dimensions this is a
picture of a mammoth it's a three
dimensional skeleton of a mammoth the
data points that doesn't fold down in
two dimensions very well but you can see
we've preserved a lot of the local
structure here you map churches works
very hard to preserve that local
structure but the sacrifice it's making
is global structure so this is an
excerpt from a great article that Andy
Cohen and Adam Pierce from Google wrote
about the algorithm the link is above
it's got lots of sliders and widgets and
parameter tools that you can use to
explore how and why the algorithm works
and what it does on your various data
sets it's a really nice place to get
started with understanding how you Maps
gonna behave on real data all right
there's a lot of validation and read the
docs feel free to pop over those and
give those a read that's easy to find
via Google if you want to get into more
a little more theory my colleague Leland
McKenna's gave an excellent Tsai talk in
2018 on you map or at PI data in LA and
2019 yesterday it's also good alright or
you could just pip and stall it right
now and start using it on your data and
see how
does alright back to looking at your
data now we have it a mentioned ruction
algorithm I'd like to use it let's use
it to look at our data suite that's
visible alright so we see we're an you
map on the numeric data I just showed
you with a Manhattan distance that was
the embedding we chose we found a two
dimensional Euclidean space for it and
we specified the metric directly in the
U map algorithm there you can see where
we pass it in l1 and Manhattan are the
same metric interestingly it looks like
this data lives on what I would call a
one-dimensional manifold alright it
lives on one smooth arc in that space so
now a quick note to be warned on you map
the XY coordinates here aren't
meaningful in any particular way we have
tried to preserve the topological
structure of the data so here that could
have come off as a sinusoidal curve it
could have come off as a straight line
it could have come off as a u or a C all
of those have the same when I'm gonna go
topological structure or local
relationships being preserved so don't
place a lot of faith in the X Y
coordinates themselves look at the
structure that you're seeing within the
data here I've colored it by SRM which
is standard reference method which is
just a way to determine what a beer
color is because I thought that would be
really insightful on looking at the data
and it proves to not have anything to do
with the manifold we've learned and that
makes us a little sad but that's ok we
switched back in color by something
different we're gonna color by overall
beer rating we didn't use that in our
embedding we held it back and we're
curious to see how it might relate and
we are perhaps not entirely surprised
that that one dimensional manifold lines
up almost perfectly with the overall
score of the bureau the overall ranking
of those beer styles so the next thing
I'm going to do here is I would do an
interactive hover tool with boquete
enhance each of the data points with
extra information and then start
exploring what those points actually are
so I did that and I added the labels to
here cuz hover tools in boquete are hard
to do inside a slideshow and it turns
out that this is what
your advocate reviewers think of beer
styles in the far bottom-left corner
you've got light lagers low-alcohol
beers these sorts of things they tend to
be ranked very poorly by beer advocate
users so poorly they've torn the
manifold and they've lived their living
off a little cluster all on their own in
the bottom left corner when you jump
into the actual sort of manifold itself
you get into the sort of standard lagers
and you wander along the lager getting
more and more popular as you go and you
hit porters and stouts and then you
wander down into the bottom right corner
the things people really really like on
beer advocates and you end up getting
you know red ales and Imperial IPAs and
quadruples and lambics these are big
bold very flavor for beers which all
have a high alcohol by volume ratio but
I'm sure that has nothing to do with
anything it's all about the flavor
all right so what if you didn't have
nice número features to represent your
data what if instead you had categorical
data all right let's take a different
lens on the data to illustrate how we
might go about dealing with that all
right let's say we're still interested
in beer style that's easy but now we
want to say beer styles are similar if
lots of the same people review that beer
style alright so this isn't how you
thought about it this isn't the ranking
this is if you all looked at the same
beer style all right
that's easy enough to do let's pivot
we've done the group buy before you said
all right well what do we want to what
are our points beer style we're gonna
group by beer style now what do we want
review or profile the trick here is
going to be in our aggregator we've got
a whole bunch of extra variables again
because we're going to want to enrich
and color by them later on so we're
gonna carry them down but our embedding
is all about these review profile names
and the trick is in our aggregator what
we're gonna do is we're gonna take all
of the unique profile names we're gonna
glue them together or pack them together
into a space separated string this is a
big long string or sentence of the
reviewers who reviewed a beer style
clops is down to 104 rows again you can
see the interesting row there is a
review for profile
list which is that string of one of
reviewers but I hear you in the audience
calling out John how does that string
help me vectorize or how does it help me
represent myself as numbers that you
just represented a big long string well
count for vectorize to the rescue SK
learn has this really wonderful function
called count vectorize which can turn a
space separated or whatever separated
string into a big sparse matrix
representation of that string what it's
going to go through is it's gonna split
the string on spaces and then it's gonna
go through and count every one of those
tokens and its gonna make a column for
every token that appears in your entire
data set so that is a column for every
reviewer who has shown up in beer
advocacy reviews and then it's going to
put a little tick of one if that beer
reviewer reviewed our beer style and so
this is gonna build a giant sparse
matrix of beer styles by reviewers and
there's gonna be lots and lots of
reviewers and most of the entries in
this are going to be 0 and so it's a
massive sparse matrix sparse matrix are
ideal because we don't actually write
any of those zeros down when we store
them in memory we're only in a store the
nonzero entries of the matrix okay now
we have a nice numerical representation
of our data mostly zeros some of them
are ones one row per beer style one
column per reviewer our first task has
been accomplished we've represented our
data as numbers beer styles are a bag of
reviewers and by bag
I just mean unordered collection alright
now that we have a representation we can
move on to talking about distance we
need to come up with a good distance
across this representation this is going
to be easier in the categorical sense
that it was the continuous sense because
there's a lot of less loosey-goosey
choices to Mike from to answer this
question I'm going to ask you one
question about your data two counts
matter the answer in this case this
counts don't matter we don't care how
often a review a review to be our style
we're caring about which
unique reviewers reviewed the individual
beer style
so our beer styles are sets of reviewers
sets is just a collection where every
element inside it is unique and for set
based representation there's a really
easy go to distance measure called
jacquard which is just looking at the
intersection of your two sets divided by
the union of your two cents we're gonna
move from you Jaccard similarity to ease
your cart distance by doing a one- the
intersection over the Union that's fine
but this score is going to be one when
you have absolutely none of your sets in
common none of your reviewers exist in
both beer styles none of your viewers
reviewed both style your style so be
zero when all of the reviewers of the
one beer style reviewed the other one as
well
and so we have a nice distance function
overtop of sets now we've done all the
hard work it's time for the fun part I
run you map I pass in metric equals your
card I get a different embedding let's
see what this embedding does this is a
very different embedding than the one by
rating this is by reviewers I'm gonna
color this one good it's divisible by
popularity my popularity I mean the
number of reviews of that beer style and
I'm gonna play the same hover game as
before I'm gonna hover over all the data
points and explore them it's been a
bunch of time playing in MySpace and
then I'm gonna label this picture so you
can see what sort of I I came up with in
the bottom left corner here you have
strange brews these are very odd beers
that I had not heard of many of but it
turns out that people who like strange
beer styles like all of the strange beer
styles and they go out and try them all
as you wander up along that manifold you
hit wild yeast beers these are lambics
and these are like Belgian beers with
wild yeasts and really powerful flavors
that are really nice you hit up the
specialist community there you can see
there are a lot of reviews about those
beers and they're quite close to strange
beers because they're not sort of in the
common mass market you wander down you
hit the lighter beers and the loggers on
the blue manifold coming down and from
that you have two paths you can choose
you can either wander through English
beers or you can wander down through
pilsners and that brings you to European
beer styles and sort of the bottom right
corner
your appearance two beer styles
transition up into American IPAs which
are very similar to strong ales and
strong IPAs which are at the very top of
your space and then Belgian beers live
off and their own little chunk to just
to the left of the IPAs and so you've
learned something very quickly about
beer styles and how they relate to each
other
just by embedding these with respect to
who reviewed what so but what I did was
a very general process notice I'm doing
this on beer styles and not datasets
that the you know financial data or
malware or anything fun like that this
is in order to remind you that this is
all flexible general and you can drop
and replace your own data for this data
without any problems I could also just
say beers or sets of reviewers walk
through exactly the same process do a
group by doom account vectorize assume
Jaccard distance and embed that gives me
this plot for beers are sets of viewers
I've colored this by brewery the quick
easy thing to take note of here is that
a lot of those colors are fairly
cohesive there are lots and lots of
colors because there's lots and lots of
breweries but the cohesion there says oh
if someone has reviewed a beer from a
brewery they often go out and review all
of the other beers from a brewery
they're like oh I really like cascade
brewery they make fantastic things I'm
going to drink and review all of their
beers and so you get these coherent
clusters you could take that you can
filter again but by the way of metrics
account that's where you pass it in the
bottom right corner and you say oh no no
I don't know what the most popular bill
is Spears that's great I'll go back to
my data frame I filter the beers that
have only had 100 reviews that gives me
all my popular beers I embed those into
a space I get exactly the same style of
things as popular beer or normal beer it
all comes out you still have that
coherent brewery effect maybe leads you
to the next question
what if breweries were sets of reviewers
do I see a similar effect there so I
take that I take my distance to be
account I embed into a space and I get
this lovely embedding here so this is a
two dimensional space done with you map
I've colored the breweries by their
number of reviews each point is a
brewery breweries are similar if many of
the same people reviewed their beers you
see something that is very common for
doing is you called embedding you see in
the center there's this red very intense
group of breweries these are the very
popular breweries that everyone has
reviewed so everyone in the data set has
reviewed them and so they get pulled
very very close together
massive extremely popular things as you
wander out you get into more local
geographic areas of your data and that's
because less and less reviewers have
done them and so those reviewers tend to
be more concentrated in geographic
regions and you get very fine resolution
at Lois Devil's Lee tales in the top
left you have Canadian breweries which I
can do quickly by mousing over and
looking at them like oh I know that
brewery you get clusters of Vancouver
breweries and clusters of Ontario
breweries and so you have a sort of a
very very local extra piece of
information contained in the details
from there you can wander down to
European breweries or up to Central
American breweries in the top top corner
you have New Zealand and Australian
breweries get clustered together because
people who review their beers tend to
review all of the Australian breweries
or all of the New Zealand breweries and
the to review each other's beers a bit
as well and so those partition off into
their own chunks you jump to the other
side of that big hub and you get
Midwestern breweries coming down to sort
of Colorado breweries Texas breweries
you can go out to California or you can
sort of transition down to southeast
breweries Californian breweries really
group up together and and folks really
like up on in Californian breweries I
tried just the Californian breweries but
they're a little close to the Oregon and
Washington State breweries which also
have this sort of I cluster up together
which says oh these breweries stick
together and people like all of the
beers from those regions if you instead
went southeast you could go down to New
York and up to New England and carry on
so amusingly we've by examining the
structure of breweries with respect to
who reviews them we've learned
geographic information about North
America as well as things about sort of
brewing culture within North America so
which is kind of fun another twist you
can do when you're playing
sort of medicine games are exploring and
embedding is if you're looking at
Californian breweries and you find a
brewery that is dead set right in the
middle of that cluster and it's not a
California brewery that's maybe
interesting this may be a story there
and you can start exploring these things
for outliers and what do these things is
not like the other games and start
seeing what pulled that brewery into
that particular region okay
this finishes our stories of breweries
and how the group geographically let's
examine by who reviews them
the next question is maybe whether what
styles of beers those breweries produce
and that might give it different an
interesting lens onto our data another
way to phrase that is what if counts did
matter so I'll tell you why let's talk
about variable linked with categorical
data where counts matter representations
I'm going to say a breweries a bag of
beer styles it makes but what if many
breweries have made most styles of beer
over the length of their lifespan so
you've got one brewery that's really
know well well known for its American
IPAs but once in 2003 they made a German
double Bock there's another german
brewery that makes lots of german
double-box it is well known for it but
once made an American IPA back in 2009
never did it again are those the same
breweries or they similar breweries and
you might argue no they're not I want to
take the distribution of the number of
beers they make or popularity of their
beers into account to do that we're
gonna instead of saying made or not made
we're going to count the number of
reviews each style of beer has for each
brewery alright then we're gonna pull
out count vectorize it helped us before
turns out it'll help us again this is
exactly the same thing we did last time
we we build that long list of spear
styles that the brewery made we did a
group by we aggregated together into the
space or comma separated list then we
did a count vectorize it's not omitting
a one or a zero now because we have beer
styles showing up many many times
it's omitting counts of the numbers of
each of those beer styles was met was
reviewed for a given brewery now if we
want to breweries that are have
different popularity to be on the same
footing like we all we all brew the same
exact same amounts of beer but people
review your brewery twice as often as
mine
we both do IPAs and English Porter's if
we think those should be on the same
foothold we're gonna do an l1
normalization we're going to divide that
row by the sum of the row and now we
have probabilities of making a beer and
the way to think of this is the brewer
wakes up in the morning he rolls a die
it's like I'm gonna make Oh American
IPAs today makes that beer and goes on
out and so this is a vector of
probabilities of making a beer style now
if we were statisticians you might
instead of saying that's a vector of
probabilities say that a brewery is a
multinomial distribution across our beer
style space that's quite nice but it's
just another way of phrasing the
previous statement we're gonna take all
of those vectors or multinomial s we're
going to stack them on top of each other
and now we have a matrix of breweries
buy beer style that takes our counts
into account now we need a distance
measure on it that's a representation
and because we're not doing unsupervised
learning we need their distance measure
to be justifiable and supportable
because we don't have labels but we did
just say that each one of those rows is
a multi no meal over beer style space so
multinomial is as stats I wonder if
statistician can help me win counts
matter distance it turns out theoretical
statistics to the rescue is something
you hear shouted across the hills of LA
all the time I'm absolutely certain all
right so it turns out in the 50s they
did some theoretical statistics and
proved that there is a Fisher
information correct distance measure
across the parameters of a multinomial
distribution there's a couple of
reference papers that are much more
modern and easy to read if you would
like to delve into that in any more
detail but the cut in the dry of this is
it turns out there's a you essentially
unique roumanian manifold Delta
where the points are distributions whose
distance function is derived from Fisher
information metric F on this manifold
it's called Fisher information metric
you can look at compute geodesics on
that manifold and the multinomial
distributions are points along those
geodesics it turns out that if we
approximate that with our coasts we get
a distance called Hellinger distance and
it's a provable correct measuring
distance between multinomial
distributions that's very nice the way
to describe that in cartoons is I have
two bags of animals and I'm gonna reach
into each bag and pull out an animal and
I'm gonna count the number of times I
see each type of animal if I can't tell
the difference between those bags from
the animals I'm pulling out they are the
same bag as far as this multinomial is
concerned and so the amount of
information I have lost by using one bag
to represent the other bag is the
distance between those bags or
multinomial z-- that is Hellinger
distance okay now a brewery is a bag of
the beer styles it makes with a distance
that's Hellinger because counts matter
and so now we can look at our data we do
you map with metric equals Hellinger in
this case instead of metric equals
jacquard we get this embedding out we
get gooses and lambics we get Belgians
we get American IPAs and the main
cluster these are again breweries that
mostly brew those beers I've colored by
your predominant beer style and it seems
to be having a really strong effect
Russian imperial stouts are the
breweries that brew those but they also
agree lots of Imperial IPA so they end
up being close together German beers
coming down we get Czech transition it
to Czech beers European lagers and in
the bottom cluster you have the American
loggers there's a brewery is like Coors
and fosters in that style of thing okay
this is a very different embedding than
a previous Geographic based embedding
but we've learned something about
breweries and the styles of beers they
make
but where else have I heard of bags of
counts before that sounds really really
familiar documents if you talk to anyone
in NLP they're going to say oh I often
represent my documents as bags of words
and so if we want to do unsupervised
learning on documents we've got
documents our bags of words and
everything we just did applies so
documents are variable with categorical
data win counts matter representation
this should look very familiar very
common way to represent a document as a
bag of words more precisely a bag of
counts of those words we did account
vectorize that's exactly what we did
with breweries and bags of beer styles
we normalized those because we want
documents of different lengths to be on
the same footing now we have a document
is a bag of probabilities that's just
this multinomial over the word space
instead of over the beer style space
that all falls out very naturally now a
corpus is this document by word matrix
with probabilities in there that's
mostly good the one problem that kicks
up here is you notice that when we did
the brewery's embedding the predominant
beer style that each brewery made had a
really big effect at pulling those
breweries together in english or many
other languages you have things called
stop words which are words or you can
think of as beer styles that pull all of
the documents together and so we really
like to correct for that there are a
number of ways to do that via sort of
removing expectation a few other tricks
this is words like if and or' those
other side of soft words you're gonna
see lots of them in every document but a
really common thing and an easy thing to
do in NLP literature is something called
term frequency inverse document
frequency that is normalize each column
by how often that word appears in all of
my documents you can just swap out count
vectorizer for tf-idf vectorizer and
everything just works from that on okay
now we need a distance measure but I
think everyone knows the punch line I've
got that multinomial
when counts mattered well that document
is a bag of words distances Hellinger
everything I just did previously applies
here all over the theory is the same we
have an embedding of documents documents
are variable with gotta call data with
counts matter we look at our data we get
that exploded picture we had previously
so that would fact was a bedding of
documents each point there was a
document two documents are close to each
other if they end up using many of the
same words in the same proportion
you get clusters of documents in this
space those of those big intense yellow
bursts which are documents they're
talking about the same thing generalizes
though we could say say bag by grams
instead of documents
that's fine instead of words we say oh
no order matters a little bit I'm gonna
count vectorized with by grams and
that's word two pairs of words that
appear next to each other that gives me
a very nice representation at fragments
by space even more which is a very nice
thing to do that only requires you
changing the one line of code in your
count vectorizer which is in gram to
bracket 2 comma 2 all right
that's we've been calling doc Mapp ie
you map on documents but you said all
the things words are things how am I
gonna do this with words well there are
lots of ways to embed words into a
vector space word to vac glove fast tax
these already exist what we're looking
for is a way to embed words directly
into a very low dimensional space in
such a way that similar words the
similar meanings end up being close
together and you can now visualize and
explore those is what we very like to do
turns out there's a thing called the
distributional hypothesis was written by
a famous linguist named John Firth in
the 50s you shall know a word by the
company it keeps that is to say don't
define a word for me show it to me in a
whole pile of sentences and I will
extrapolate the meaning of the word from
its usage all right so a word is a
document of all the sentences that
contain it because the documents just a
collection of sentences so if you hand
me a whole pile of sentences with a word
in it
that's a document and if I'm gonna go
sort of standard NLP way instead of
sentences I might say context which is I
don't want the whole sentence I just
want the small sub sentence around that
word that's fine or window that would be
another
word you could describe the small region
around an individual word you could play
kernels over those and you could do a
number of other things that I'm not
gonna get into in this talk but they can
affect your results when you do this
analysis all right word documents are
multinomial over the vocabulary so a
word is a document there's multinomial
of the words that co-occurred with it in
a sentence now I've just described this
as a problem we've already solved at
least twice in this talk so we can
reduce that problem we've already solved
words our documents which are variable
with categorical data where accounts
matter word is a bag of nearby words
distances Hellinger we have an embedding
let's look at our data this is an
embedding of Yelp reviews into the words
from Yelp reviews into a two dimensional
space and you end up having a tremendous
amount of your structure actually being
preserved there you have quesadilla
fajitas taco you have Mexican food
buried down in the very bottom of the
space if you look on the left you have
sashimi salmon fish the whole bottom
area is talking about kinds of food you
can move up into drinks on the right you
can move up into regions and places on
the upper right on the up top you get
hipster pretentious furnish'd you get
other things up that way you and so you
can wander around your space and you can
learn how words are being used in your
corpus and so you've learned not about
language in general but how language is
being used within Yelp in this
particular case that's what we've been
calling a word map or you map on words
all right but we aren't limited to beer
a language we've done all of the hard
work now we can pivot to lots of fun
different problems if you like doing
traditional topic modeling like oh I'm
gonna do Lda or pls a I can do that I
can say a document is now a topic well
those all generate you multinomial of
topics wait I know the distance function
on a multinomial I can in do use
Hellinger distance and I can embed those
into a low dimensional space in a
slightly different way and these give
you documents
malware is a bag of the commands that it
runs when you run it in a virtual
machine this is very general you see I
brought a piece of malware in a virtual
machine I look at the network
connections it establishes or the
commands that it runs each of those is a
token or a word I treat the malware as
the sentence that is those I count
vectorize I you map in bed with
Hellinger I end up getting an
interesting low dimensional embedding
here this is in fact colored by the
antivirus label that you have you get
interesting things if you notice there
are three very distinct red blobs there
they were label the same thing by an
antivirus some piece of software but
they were behaving wildly differently
but consistently amongst themselves when
run on machines in a virtual environment
so you found three totally different
strains of a particular malware
particular virus without any labels in a
totally unsupervised fashion accounts
are bags of forums if you're looking at
web forums or edits you could do that
sort of thing you are where you post
honey pots if you've got sessions where
people log into honey pots and you look
at them you like oh I'm gonna look at
the series of commands you run when you
log onto my honeypot to try to conquer
my box I'm going to describe a session
as that sequence of commands you run I
think order might matter a little bit
okay I'll look at Ingram's or by grams
across that BAM I embed into low
dimensional space this is colored by the
type of virus or malware the individual
honeypot session is trying to download
to exploit the box you get a very
natural grouping that matches what's
actually happening your data you could
take sub reddits if you wanted to
explore all of the sub reddits on reddit
you could say oh two sub reddits are
similar if they have the set of users in
the same way we had set of reviewers
before and you could explore sub reddits
to say oh these two sub reddits are
really talking about the same thing
because they have the same community he
really likes them all right in other
words insert your thing here is a bag
set vector of insert your other thing
here and now you two can go off and
embed all of the things describe it that
way and you're done
everything
else should just work alright you can
install the software there if you're
running this in 2019 and not 2020 you're
gonna have to use the dev version if you
would like to have those pretty plots
that I've been doing there in the 0.42
version of you map the installation
instructions are there but they are also
the top of every notebook in the repo
reproduce to me matters that is the
github repo where you can download both
the talk and all of the notebooks that
will allow you to go and embed all your
things thank you I have like 40 seconds
for questions anyone wait for the mic so
in all those a lot of these examples so
for instance beer reviewers are very
subject to fashion IPA was not
fashionable a few years ago and now it's
very fashionable mall where you're gonna
have different levels of attacks that
come over time like every every example
that you're giving here I can easily see
wanting to do clustering over time and a
lot of people would immediately jump to
cluster by day or cluster by month but
I'm curious to think like can you come
up with more natural clustering methods
like how would you incorporate time into
these models and say like well we're
gonna do a two-week cluster and then the
trend goes to 6 weeks and then it goes
back to 2 weeks then one week then 10
weeks you get what I'm saying I totally
get what you're saying and you should
come to my idea to talk next year
because that is the current plan for
this year the short answer is the thing
we're planning to do now next is a
regularized you map where I run you map
in multiple time slices and I regularize
with anchor points between those time
slices so that the embedding is line up
with each other and so you can watch
your points move through your space over
time and then I've got essentially you
can see if instead of a two dimensional
view of the data I've got a three
dimensional view of the data that is
smooth and meaningful across time and I
can cluster in that space
so most of your examples were
multinomial and towards the end yeah so
are there cases where you had to use
other distributions like some other
examples and then therefore you have to
change the distance which you choose and
so on
so in sort of the categorical space the
the vast vast majority of problems we
have had are people interested in either
set based or multinomial and so those
are accounts matter or counts don't
matter and it has covered more than 90%
of the actual use cases that we've
encountered with people trying to deal
with these problems but you could do the
same thing on other fun distributions
the other tiny use case we have played
with is Vassar Stein distance across
distributions if you didn't have multi
what is the example they're like what is
the real-world use case have you had a
time series of data and it's not
categorical it's now ordinal because
those time times matter so you can look
at in fact those honey pots and look at
when people are doing keystrokes on
those yeah so in all the examples that
you've shown it's appear to be a
two-dimensional embedding which is good
because then we can actually look at it
is there anything in and I realized part
of it is you might be looking for two
dimensional manifolds is there anything
inherently saying you know three
dimensional four dimensional no okay
putting on slides is the only actual
difference if you set in components and
you map to 20 you embed it into a 20
dimensional manifold embedding into a
higher dimensional manifold is often
useful if you're gonna be doing
clustering but not visualization sure
yeah I think if there no other questions
I'm out of time so thank you again